As you all know intuitively whether or
not you've actually thought about it.
Language is made up of individual sounds
that when combined together give us the
words that we use in speech.
The scientific study of these
sounds is called phonetics.
When we understand the language,
we can distinguish between the sounds
that exist in that language combined
sounds together to form words and
understand others when they combine sounds
together to form words at their own.
But when you hear someone talking in a
language that you know next to nothing
about the individual
sounds strung together,
don't form words in your ears.
They're perceived as generous
because of the inherent knowledge that
we have of the sound system that exists
in our native language and the knowledge
that we have of the written language
that we've learned through study.
Generally speaking,
we know how a word ought to be
pronounced just by looking at it,
even though in some languages,
English among them,
the combination of letters in a word
doesn't necessarily suggest how to
pronounce it.
For example,
a native speaker knows that doubt
is pronounced doubt, not doubt,
but that kernel is pronounced colonel,
not colo now and that no and know
are pronounced exactly the same.
This inconsistency between spelling
and pronunciation has been famously
illustrated by this word often
attributed to George Bernard Shaw.
Though its origins seems unclear,
which spells fish using
the g h as in tough,
the o as in women and
the TCI as in nation.
Also potato.
Yeah,
but although we do know how to
pronounce many words by sight,
what about words we've never
pronounced out loud before?
What about words in other languages?
Who's spellings and pronunciations are
unclear to us for that we have the IPA.
IPA stands for international phonetic
alphabet and unlike other reselling
systems that only worked
for native speakers,
Dick Shun Narr re the IPA include
standardized phonetic representations for
every sound that exists
in every known language.
The international phonetic alphabet
offers a letter or symbol that corresponds
to every individual sound that
exists in the languages of the world.
This makes learning the IPA extremely
useful indeed prerequisite for anyone
who's interested in the serious
study of language. To start off,
it's best to familiarize yourself
with the sounds that exist in your own
language.
So today I will be presenting you with
the IPA symbols and their corresponding
towns for the consonants in
the English language. Uh,
constantly is formed when in some way we
restrict the passage of air through the
vocal track by,
among other things,
the moving or contorting
of our lips and tones.
All consonant sounds are classified
according to three basic criteria,
place of articulation, which refers to
where the sound is produced in the mouth,
manner of articulation,
which refers to how the sound is
produced in the mouth and voicing,
which tells you whether or not the sound
is produced with the vibration of the
vocal chords.
In this,
this episode I will describe the consonant
sounds according to their place of
articulation.
You'll have to wait until part two to
hear about how the sounds are classified
according to the other two criteria.
As I present the different
places of articulation,
I'll also placed on the screen the IPA
symbol that corresponds to each of the
consonants that are made at
each place of articulation.
The sounds that I will be producing
here will be shown using the IPA symbol
between two slashes on the screen.
The slashes indicate that at phone
nemic transcription is being used.
Don't worry too much about the terminology
now in future videos I'll go into
greater depth on this subject.
Here we go.
A bilabial is a sound produced using
bold lips by meaning two and Lavey over
referring to the lip and English.
There are three
as in buckle
as in potato and ma as in muscle,
a lab.
You know dental is a sound that's made
by touching the bottom of the upper teeth
to the lower lip. In English there
are two sentence made this way
as in future and as in vase or vase.
An interdental is this sound made by
placing the tongue between the top and
bottom teeth in English there are two
as in think and as in those then
you thought all the symbols,
we're going to be easy and Alveolar is
a sound that's made by touching the tip
of the tongue on the alveolar
ridge. That weird, hard,
bumpy thing right behind
the front teeth in English.
There are seven sentence made.
This as in top D as in danger,
no as in nothing,
so as an sourcer,
Z as in Zombie,
look as in lake and rough in retro note.
The official sound for the right side up
are is as in the Spanish word Pero Pero
Kalyan although the upside down our is
the official symbol for the r sound in
English. Sometimes we cooperate to the
right side up our for transcription.
It is very common to do this
so keep an eye out for it.
A post lb layer is a sound that's produced
by placing the tip of the tongue just
behind the alveolar ridge and sort
of bunching up the tongue behind it.
These sounds are generally considered
partially palatalized because they share
some characteristics with the pellet
holes which we'll discuss in a moment.
In English there are four post lb there,
consonants,
cheap as in cheese,
J as in jeep,
she as in sheep and as an measure or
when doing transcription in English.
Sometimes these other symbols are used
in place of the ones that I showed you so
keep an eye out for that as well.
A palatal is a sound that's
made by bringing the center
of the tongue up to the
hard palate,
the hard part of the roof of your mouth
located just behind the Alveolar Ridge
in English.
There is only one true
palatal yet as in you,
uh, Vilar is a sound that's produced by
bringing the back of the tongue up to the
soft palate,
the soft part of the roof of the mouth,
also known as the Villum in English.
There are three sounds made this way
as in key.
Good as in good and
isn't seen.
Note this sound is a curious
one in English and really
only occurs at the end of
a word.
In the example given earlier,
some may think that they pronounced the
gut at the end of seeing and some may in
fact pronounce it,
but it's far more common to hear the
Vilar that we've already mentioned.
It's far more common to hear
seeing instead of seeing good.
Generally the only time you'll ever
hear seeing good is if someone's over
annunciating.
As in the following example,
I think we need to sing a duet with
what do you think we need to do?
Seeing a duet,
a glottal was a sound that's produced
by the passing of air through the open
Gladys in this part of the neck
as in house. I know what you're
thinking. What about the w?
The sound as in water is a
co articulated consonant,
meaning that it's produced at
two places of articulation.
It's a bilabial because it's produced
with both lips and a Vilar because of the
position of the tongue.
For that reason,
it defies easy classification and is
sometimes known as a lady. Oh, Vilar.
Well,
there you have it.
All of the consonants classified
according to their place of articulation.
Stay tuned for part two where we will
discuss the other two criteria that help
us classify these consonants.
Sounds.